Please welcome Navyn Salem.
(audience cheering)
I'm very honored to meet you, I really love your story.
How did you end up on this trip in the first place?
So, I mean, really the reason behind it is my dad,
and he's from Tanzania, along with my grandparents
and great grandparents.
So we have a long family history in East Africa.
And also at the same time,
my daughters were all about under the age of five.
And so I packed my bags one day and went to
Dar Es Salaam, Tanzania,
to see what was going on in the world.
And wanted to see like what's missing,
what needs to be done, what action needs to be taken.
And I started to learn about malnutrition
and understood that 8,000 children a day
were dying from something that is 100% preventable,
which is hunger and malnutrition.
So just looking into my own daughter's eyes, right,
and understanding that mothers every single day
are losing their children
to something that we know how to treat.
And I really felt that urgency,
because obviously I didn't have a lot of free time
at that moment with all of these little kids
to take care of, but that urgency really stayed with me
and it kept me up at night.
And I knew that I had do something about it
and I didn't have any experience,
I had never worked for a nonprofit before,
I have no manufacturing experience, nothing.
But I was like, if we don't do something
then lives are at stake.
And this is an opportunity and a responsibility
to do something at that moment and take action.
I mean-
(audience applauds)
Where did you, you go, like, where did you start?
Did people take you seriously?
What was your first lesson that we could all learn from?
Yeah, I mean,
I traveled with a bunch of different nonprofits
and I learned about their philosophies, their mandates,
how they worked and I came home and I said,
I wanna do this completely differently.
I remember having a follow up call with them and saying,
I have this idea to start a business but it's a nonprofit,
but it's a business.
And so we can do something at scale,
we can feed these children at scale,
and they said, that's not how it's done.
And so for 24 hours
I was really sad that my idea was terrible idea.
And then I thought to myself, wait a second,
I've only been in this business for 20 minutes, 24 hours,
these people have been in for 20 years,
maybe they've just been there too long,
maybe this is the way of the future, let's give it a try.
So I just picked myself back up
and I'm like, we're gonna go for it,
and we're gonna make this food at scale,
and we're gonna try to reach thousands
and millions of children and make it happen.
(audience applauds)
So you have helped more than 2 million kids last year.
And what now is your goal?
The need in the world has doubled.
So what I need to do now is double the size of our factory.
So we're trying to raise money now
to be able to buy the equipment that we need,
to be able to produce more of these packets.
I brought one with me.
So we make a 1,000 005 of these every single day,
we work 24 hours a day making the product,
called Plumpy'Nut.
I have 110 people who are on my team.
We work 24 hours a day to be able to deliver these products
to 60 countries.
(audience applauds)
Did you put money from your own pocket into this endeavor?
Yes, yes, but we also, you know, I take loans from banks.
I make partnerships, we raise money,
so it's really a little bit of everything.
But definitely there's a personal investment as well.
Well, we heard that Perdue Farms
has actually been a big supporter of yours
and we are thrilled to tell you
that through working with them, we've actually yep,
here comes the big check, we've raised $25,000.
(audience applauds)
Wow.
Courtesy of Perdue.
And Chris Miller, my producing partner, and I wanna,
match that also, so it'll be $50,000.
(audience applauds)
Thank you, thank you so much for everything that you do.
Thank you, Drew
Oh my God, Navyn,
to the drewbarrymoreshow.com
to find out more about Navyn's mission to end world hunger
and know how you can help start today, thank you.
(upbeat music)